what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 19th
happy anniversary i've been here for
nine months now the joint is brought to
you by and we want to welcome
magnesium breakthrough you got restless
leg
syndrome you can't sleep you're tossing
and turning
squash that [__] how with magnesium
if you can't sleep but you tried
everything it's probably because your
magnesium is low
you didn't know that did you you didn't
read the book sleep magnesium
naturally helps activate the
transmitters in your brain that calm the
mind and body
what's better than that listen to me i
love [__] sleeping
for years i didn't [__] sleep i
didn't pay attention to it
and i blew up to 418 pounds now my whole
life is [__] sleeping
let me tell you what really happened my
agent sent me this product in like
january
or december before my surgery and i was
scared of covered
so i was taking the vitamin d with the
magnesium
and i noticed that i was getting a lot
better sleep
so now it's part of my who the [__] i am
i take my magnesium two
pills after dinner every day this
company magnesium breakthrough is
tremendous
they have the mass enzymes which i got
to be honest with you
the weight loss i've attributed to i
think it's because of them
because i've been taking that uh that
stuff you take like that's in yogurt
like with bio-optimizers and all that
stuff
and it's helped my digestion 150 percent
magnesium breakthrough from
bio-optimizers is the cure for sleepless
nights
it's only organic magnesium supplement
that includes you ready for this one
seven unique forms of magnesium seven
that's the full spectrum
it's helped tons of people and i could
read their testimonials all day
but here's mine you sleep like a [__]
baby yes
i make the michael jackson tea some
nights some nights i go on melatonin
but magnesium is in me every night and i
can
feel it because i sleep like a [__]
baby it lacer it takes a lot to pull
this bull [__] down
at night as you've noticed but my videos
but magnesium breakthrough works
listen if you're having trouble falling
asleep or staying asleep
make sure you get enough magnesium
they're actually seven forms of
magnesium
and you gotta get all of them if you
want the experience
that calming sleep enhancing effects
that's why i recommend
magnesium breakthrough just pop two
capsules before you go to bed
like me on an empties on a full stomach
and you'll be out like [__] desi
arnaz on a school night
listen for the joint listeners go to
magbreakthrough.com again mag
mag breakthrough dot com
slash joey and use joey 10
during the checkout to get 10 percent
off
that's magbreakthrough.com
joey and use joey 10 for 10
off and when you see the sandman tell
them [__] and i sent you [__]
remember magnesiumbreakthrough.com
joey let's get this party started it's
wednesday the 19th
we ain't got time to [__] chitta
chatter
hey how you
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
bye
so
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 19th
of may happy anniversary to joey
happy anniversary to joey happy
anniversary to joey
nine [__] months i've been in jersey
now
it's been tremendous but this all
started with a phone call
what i wanted to talk to you guys today
about something that you have to do
and you have to stick to no matter what
field you use or what field you choose
is what i meant to say
and that's your word your word in a
business
whatever the [__] you do while you're
[__] around at foot locker
or your little [__] college jobs
that's one thing
but once you pick the field where you
have a job with your career
you have to be very honest with yourself
and the people around you
the one thing i found about la that was
very disheartening
was that people would call you and say
hey man how are you doing
this is what's going on in my world i'm
[__] lighting the stage on fire in
ohio
people cannot follow me what are the
rents like in studio city
i'm moving out here you talk to them for
an hour
you give them two hours of your time you
you actually go on google
and you tell them to call these three
apartments and then you never hear from
that person again
and then one day you're driving and you
go what the [__] happened they were
moving here you call them
up and they tell you some chinese story
about [__]
uh and when i say chinese no disrespect
in spanish
when you tell a story to somebody they
always go
you know you're gonna come at me so it's
you know tell me some chinese story
about [__] uh how you were gonna move
but the landlord gave you a break on the
rent and you decided you want a headline
listen if i had a [__] nickel for
every call that was coming to la
i'd be a [__] millionaire and i know
it's a cliche line to say
but it's very true when you commit when
i call you and i go i want to get into
this
before i make that call i think of it
from all angles
and before i say it i commit to it and
sometimes i say no and people like how
can you say no to that
because i committed to all i looked at
all the angles from every opportunity
and i don't see how this is going to
help me or my career
this is helping you but it's not helping
me
so this is not what i want to do you
know
it taught me to be honest with people
comedy teaches you the truth comedy is
the truth and unless you're prepared to
face the truth
you're going to have a hard time doing
comedy as a matter of fact
any anything in life
last year we had a [__] what you call
a disaster in this country
the biggest disaster for me was the
people dying
and the biggest disaster for me was that
they closed the schools
if i didn't have kids i wouldn't have
gave a [__] about schools like i did
when i didn't have kids
but i had children and i saw the effect
on my child
and i worried about other child that's
what it's called to be empathetic that
you
go what the [__] is going on here so on
july 13th or july 12th i got a [__]
call
it's not a call i got uh my wife
came in very distressed and she goes
they just canceled school for the year
and i was faced with a dilemma okay
i have a successful podcast i have a
successful career here in california
um i created a paradise for myself my
job is two
blocks away i had my life down to a
science
but i always knew one thing
there was there used to be a a
commercial when i was growing up
on pennzoil pennzoil oil the race car
oil
and that commercial was you're going to
install your air filter
you could either pay me now or you could
pay me later
when you don't put the work in with your
kids when they're three four
five six seven eight you're gonna have a
problem when they're 13.
so your career is going to be going
great you're on top of the world
you're selling out theaters but in the
back of my mind
i'm worried about this 13 year old girl
that's starting to
act out because the strongest force in
her life
isn't around on the weekends he's around
and by that time
she'll be watching youtube and seeing
the language i use
and the part i smoke so she'll start
acting i didn't take a genius to figure
this out
this is just the way life is so
before that happened i had to take a big
look at myself and go
what is more important a podcast that
i'm doing
my stand up at the comedy store the
comedy still be there forever
comedy clubs will be there forever but
this relationship with my daughter is
only going to be here one time
she's only going to be eight once she's
only going to be
nine once she's only going to be 10 once
and i can't have a broken child
because they're not going to put them in
school i understand
it's contagious i understand they can
bring it home to parents i understand
all these things
but there has to be something that we
have to do
so i made the hardest decision i had to
do i called a friend
and that friend's name was jimmy
florentine was he my best friend at the
time
not really we were just comedy friends i
thought he was funny
i watched his show the heavy metal show
i was a fan of him
you guys know i'm a big fan of trunk i
liked uh
their other buddy i just liked the show
i would watch it i'd see michael shank
to play the guitar
you know yeah i was envious of jimmy but
he was a great kid
and he came on the podcast a couple
times we spoke about the ufos
in jersey all you [__] that are
talking about ufos now
i saw a ufo in 76 i saw the feds
collecting the [__] dirt
and i passed along to you still with the
[__] ufos
knock it off joey told you three years
ago about the ufos and 76 in jersey
75. if you don't believe me go on
[__] youtube press ufo north bergen
and the tape is right there in front of
your [__] eyes what's the matter with
you
but anyway i called jimmy and i said
jimmy i'm gonna bind i need to move
i wanted to move to bergen field or
bergen county and that's contaminated
the jewish guy went skiing and now
everybody's [__] coughing in [__]
bergen county what can i do and he said
my sister-in-law
my wife had already called the realtor
and the realtor was california worthless
like the realtor
we were looking at houses in california
it was hysterical we went to look at one
house and i told my wife i can't deal
with this guy
because everything we looked at i could
fix it i got a guy for that
i got a guy for that i got a guy how
many guys you got how many guys you got
you know so he went i just didn't want
to buy a house in california
i called jimmy florentine
he told me that his sister-in-law was a
realtor
and she specialized in homes in this
area she grew up in this area
i had my eyeball on this area i knew the
schools are open
my wife told me the schools were number
two and three in the state in this area
so i called jimmy like a man and i
explained to him that i wanted to move
and i could hear kind of sort of the
apprehension of his voice a little bit
you know again this is some [__] jerk
off comic
telling you he wants to move his [__]
family but jimmy didn't know the guy he
was dealing with
he didn't know that i don't [__] around
when i say i'm gonna do something
i attack him with both legs so i tell
you no that's it
i had my heart set on it i already knew
i was gonna move
and jimmy florentine came through within
a week we were putting office in at
homes
and within two weeks i think by august
first
we had already gotten this home uh then
we started making plans to leave on
august 19th
when i got here jimmy opened up his home
to me i remember first going to his
sister-in-law's house for a barbecue and
like [__] my heart beating out of my
chest because
i thought i had covered the name and
they're assuring me they're like
nobody here's got covert and we got home
tests if you want to take a test
so i was like these [__] people and
then they were like sunday we had
football
wednesday we meet for dinner as a family
you're invited
it was just like i was a kid
and when rogan called me the saint
joe rogan called me and said to me joey
i want you close to me i want to buy
a home for you in austin texas i said
thank you for the offer i love you at
all my heart
there's nobody i'd rather live next to
but
i got to be close to family i have no
family out there joe if i move out there
to austin i'm going to see you when i
see you and that's it
my daughter needs cousins my daughter
needs friends
my daughter doesn't need a comedy right
now i can't worry about comedy
the comedy will always be there and
next thing you know we had this house
here and uh
i'm home and at first when i came home i
thought about the ghost that i had in my
closet here
and you know what man if it was for my
daughter i'd be forced to face it and
that was the decision i made
and that's it and ever since that time i
considered jimmy florentine
and his family family i goof on them i
call them the florentine crime family
because they have fun they just the
family that
and l.a people forgot what fun was and
that l.a nothing was fun
unless somebody was showing up to your
party make sure you come
laurence fishburne's gonna be there oh
my god you know i'm gonna go talk to him
about his movie you know
here people are just people and this is
what i was looking for
and this is what i wanted you guys know
as much as i know
yeah i'm a comic yeah i do this i do
that but
one thing i talk from is from the heart
and i'm authentic and i come at you
correct the right way like a gentleman
and i'm not here to [__] blow smoke
up your ass or anything
i'm telling you that i lucked out i made
this move for my family
and i'm happy i did today's guest on my
podcast
is jimmy florentine i hope you enjoy it
stay black
what's happening jimmy florentine
what's going on six houses away
we're still [__] zooming [__] it
after this is all over
nobody's gonna want to go nowhere we're
gonna just keep [__] zooming
i'm not leaving my house to drive an
hour to go [__] zoom in connecticut
or some [__]
yeah man it's like remember you should
drive like an hour and a half for an
hour to go
what an hour to [__] get there and
they talk to you for 15 minutes then
it's an hour and a half podcast and they
want to introduce you to their [__]
mother
and then you drive an hour two hours in
traffic so your whole day went to a
[__] podcast
this is a lot better i think i think
people gonna stick to this
i feel like you got a better connection
when you're in studio though
absolutely you know absolutely
you know you got the little delay here
and all that [__] but
we're six hours away it shouldn't be a
delay no there shouldn't nothing no
[__] delay i want to start off with a
question
for you because i was talking about this
earlier in the podcast
what did you think when i called you
july 12th and told you i wanted to move
and i needed your help
what was the first thing that came to
your mind i was like i don't know if
he's serious he's probably just you know
hating la at the moment but i just said
look man i go if you move here it's
going to be quiet
nice you know neighborhood you know if
you want to move around where i live
everything's right around here there's
no chaos there's no
there's no nothing it's complete
opposite of la if you're ready for it
but you live in the suburbs you know
with kids and all that stuff playing on
the street if that's what you want you
go from the action
la so if you're ready for that it's a
quiet life
it was exactly what i wanted but what
did you think two years later
two weeks later when your sister-in-law
called you and said we're looking at
houses and
he's putting off his and what was what
was your reaction then
i couldn't believe it because i was like
i just threw it out there i go hey my
sister-in-law is a real estate agent
you know if you're interested i don't
know if you have one or whatever i don't
want to get in people's business
i just do it out they go yeah give me
your number i'm gonna give it to my wife
and i'm like okay and then
next thing you know my sister lost i
didn't want to bother you i didn't know
what was going on
my sister-in-law was like no they're
really coming i'm they're looking at a
couple houses and then
on the one close by me i'm like are you
serious he's gonna be living right here
like yeah they took the house i'm like
holy [__]
you know in our business we get calls
every day from people with promises
that they're gonna come you know i still
got a guy that calls me once a year
to tell me he's coming to la to tell
everybody to look out
that his materials on fire that they're
not going to stop him
that's for 23 years i've been getting
this call from the same [__] kid
so in our business in our world when
somebody follows through
you really [__] get blown away like
so i'm happy that you put the offer out
there and i got to blow you the [__]
away
like two weeks later we were in a house
and a month later we were on our way
here that was insane i would
say i see i figured you would move back
to like north jersey or you're from
north bergen area i've lived in
cliffside park for a long time
no i was up in that area too but when i
had a kid i said i
could get to the suburbs so they can
have a life a lawn
kids playing it's all that stuff so i
moved you know
further further south and stuff but i
wasn't i figured you were going to move
back to where you originally grew up
with all your friends
[__] no that was not happening i
considered bergen county
until the [__] jewish guy went skiing
and he came back and [__] up the
neighborhood
because that's where i was looking at
bergenfield you know
uh dumont around there and once [__]
that guy
infected bergen county lit up like a
christmas tree
so my only other option was south jersey
i didn't want to move to like down the
shore and [__] hand-to-hand combat
every weekend with the northerners so we
found the happy medium in the middle i
knew this area well from my brother
living
here so it was perfect and then
i get here and i get introduced to the
florentine crime family which is
a complete different story people been
contacting me
thinking that you guys are in the mafia
and that's not it i call them the
florentine crime family because they
should be thrown in jail for how much
fun they have
americans don't have as much fun as the
florentine crime family
from sunday football to [__] uh
kentucky derby parties to ac dc bands
playing on a lawn
uh wrestling they hired wrestlers one
year
to come to the lawn like puerto ricans
in front of the house
that is fun they should be thrown in
jail
for how much fun the florentines have
you know so
that's why i call them the florentine
crime family not because
they're involved in stealing trucks or
nothing like that it's amazing though
like
there's seven of us in the family and
like you know more about what's going on
with my family members than i do
you know you'd be like hey he's a sister
she's going to florida because she is
yeah she's been down there for two days
i'm like oh that's news to me
you know more what's going on i love him
i i
i grew up with italian families like
this that
you just weren't friends with jimmy you
just weren't friends with jimmy
i used jimmy for one thing me and jimmy
went to concerts
but me and your brother bob smoke pot
together and me and joe
knew how to steal sneakers from the
english town
raceway and your sister kathy used to
let me into the movie theater when she
paid so
i gave her free joints from time you
know that's what a family life is
i'm just not friends with jimmy and i
avoid everybody else
i'm friends with you i'm friends with
you i have a relationship with your dad
i go to the track with your dad
you're like i can't believe you got my
dad high the other day that's how i grew
up with people you know
so i'm back there again yeah no it's
great man look i knew
you know i live right outside of new
york city for a while doing stand-up you
have no life you're doing shows every
night you miss birthdays you miss
anniversaries you miss
everything because you're just dedicated
to and then when i got married and i had
kid i go i got to move back to the
suburbs and have somewhat of a normal
life
i can't just focus on stand up you know
and just live and breathe it every day
because you need you have no experience
after a while you're just doing the same
thing you're doing two or three sets a
night
you're not really living you're doing
the same routine over and over again and
you're not really experiencing anything
so
when i moved back here it was definitely
an adjustment to live back in a
neighborhood you know i didn't do that
for years i was in the high-rise little
apartment here and there whatever
i needed to be near the action but then
when i came back and real you know
had the kid and all that stuff it all
made sense and now i love it
look does it take 45 minutes to go to
new york city fine no problem you just
leave a little early it's no big deal
and the ride's enjoyable you get to
clear your mind
you listen to a little ozzy's boneyard a
little tom morello
something always pops up that you
haven't heard in a while
you know when my brother did it my
brother had a fish market
and he would leave down here at quarter
to four in the morning
we would hit the fulton fish market at
five o'clock
and we would be there until 6 30 you
know joking around with the gangsters
and the italians and the chinese people
selling fish he would deliver his six or
seven routes
and would we would be back down here by
one how beautiful is it right now
outside
phenomenal so one minute you're in the
jungle of new york city
and 45 minutes later you're in [__]
paradise we wouldn't even go in the
house
we would shower in the side of the house
take our clothes off
and jump in his heated pool and then he
would take a piece of fish out from the
day cut the head off
and we'd grilled whatever fish we had
and we'd be in the afternoon
all afternoon in his yard until six or
seven o'clock i never experienced that
before
yeah no it's great man it's uh you know
it's a it's a quieter life but look i
could you know just like you
we could do both of our things we could
beat dirt bags when we need to
on stage on a podcast or whatever and
then be and then be a dad
and hang out with other parents and go
to their sporting events and stuff like
that
you could do both you could juggle both
i never thought i could
i remember like going to therapy when i
was in my early 40s and the guy's like
i can't get married and have a family
then i'm not going to be edgy anymore
i'm not going to he's like no you're
going to have the rest of that your
chaos
the rest of your life that that side of
your life is going to be all set
and then you can focus on your career
you'll actually do better once you have
that other chaos
dating crazy women this and that or just
this craziness going on and having
nothing
to come home to because you'll look
forward to it and you'll have both
your career will actually go better and
i was like no wayne he was right
you know last christmas i had like a
little get-together two christmases ago
in l.a
and we had a couple families there you
know mercy's friends
and this one lady kept talking about
instagram on christmas
she just wouldn't shut the [__] up about
instagram and her friends and
the stories and this and that and i was
like you know what i gotta get away from
these people
like it's time to get the [__] away from
these instagram people that that's all
they talk about
it's pictures and instagram and more
pictures and
here nobody talks about instagram nobody
wants to take a picture here at the
store
nobody [__] says a word to everybody
puts their pants on one leg at a time
but the other thing i noticed when i
first got here
that you and i laughed about was i drove
past your block one day
and i saw nine [__] kids in like a
thing
pushing people down a hill and i'm like
that's the little rascals
and then you invited me into your house
and they were in the basement
and they all came up me and my daughter
were standing there
and it was just surreal that all of a
sudden
uh jimmy yells downstairs luke come on
up
you know go outside mercy's here or
something and it was one kid after the
other all different [__] sizes
and i called them the little rascals
after that that block is the little red
there's not a block in america
that has those amount of kids out like
that and now my block is starting to get
it
because i've you know i initiate it i go
out there at three o'clock
and play softball with her and then the
people across the street come out he
comes out with the hockey stick
then the two [__] across the street
come out and the next thing you know
i got five kids out there two with
helmets on and i feel like rocky balboa
throwing balls and [__] like that you
know
it's just i wanted my daughter
to have listen i didn't want my daughter
robbing gas stations in north bergen
i didn't want my daughter robbing beer
trucks but i wanted my daughter
like your son to have that jersey
normality to them
to have that jersey toughness to them
there's a certain
toughness that you have as a kid i was
watching those kids in l.a
and boy they're going to have a hard
[__] time when they grow up
you know between the treehugger parents
and the [__]
views and stuff like that and i wanted
something
different i see how you raise your boy i
see that every night
we're doing something we have activities
i mean for god's sake
jimmy i had to stop smoking pot because
i'm embarrassed to be about
by another parents with reefer on my
body
because i didn't want to make a bad
impression like a [__] junkie you
know so
thank you i just wanted to thank you for
giving me the opportunity
for your family to accepting our family
like family and
uh for us to be able to raise our kids
jersey style eating white castles
getting contaminated gut eating carvel
ice cream you know
yeah remember we took them to the white
castle we sat in the park a lot to drive
through and they ate it for the first
time and then
we got eaten there was a kid drunk at
two o'clock in the morning
and go we got to experience this sat in
the park a lot of them it's great
and there's just like a certain jersey
toughness you get as a kid i look at my
life and i go jesus christ
i've gone through all these things you
know you get a tough skin
from getting your balls busted like your
two friends that
come over for [__] football you just
learn to have tough skin
but the thing you also learn here is
like that story you told me
about the wrestler i don't want to [__]
it up you say it about the wrestler that
you
used to take pictures outside the garden
and what you put up with just for the
wrestling pictures
now everybody else in this country would
take that story
and weave that into a therapist like
they would
make that life put them on the sleeve
and they would live their life saying
that story well
i got molested by a wrestler as a child
you know what i'm saying
not you you put a spin on it and it is
one of the funniest stories i've ever
heard in my life give it to these
[__]
yeah why you know i told the story on
the stern show originally i didn't i
didn't think it was that interesting
but uh you know when i told it everybody
went crazy so
i'm 14 years old my dad's taking the
mass
wrestle match at madison square garden
once a month we go there
first of all you had to be 16 years old
to get in i was only like 14
because they would have blood so since
there was blood you had to be 16.
so it wasn't a bunch of kids back then
it was mostly adults that were into the
wrestling
so i wear my mom's platform shoes and
bell bottoms to
to seem taller so my mom had those gene
simmons platform shoes i'd wear them
i mean how how weird is that that that's
how i get it and you know like all right
he must look 16. they would never check
so i'm going this matches there's a guy
out front
outside the garden every month selling
wrestling pictures he was a wrestling
photographer so he was always in the
front row
you know taking the pictures so he'd
sell them for like a dollar a piece so
we'd always know where he was before the
match
we always go hit him up my dad would
give me 10 bucks i could buy 10 pictures
and then the guy's like hey um you know
i'll give you my address
give me your address and i'll send you
some pictures in the mail because i go
to all the matches even the ones that
aren't on tv
certainly started sending me pictures in
the mail and then the next time i go
goes give me a home number i'll tell you
who won the matches
after you know the ones that aren't on
tv so the guy would call me and he'd be
breathing heavy on the other end i
didn't know i was 14.
i thought he just came in from a jog
you know meanwhile the guy weighed like
350 pounds what the [__] this guy
jogging
so he must have been jerking off on the
other end i had no clue i just wanted to
find out if
martino felt they're not
i was willing to put up with it so then
it
comes to the point we go to um asbury
park convention hall
our parents let us go to the match by
ourselves we're 15 maybe 14 or 15 at the
time we take the train down there
and we're in the nosebleed seats and
he's at the match in the front row
he comes up in between a match he goes
hey you want to go sit in the front see
i got two seats in the front
who wants to go sit in the uh front row
with me so me and my friend michael will
go
so we go down there and we get to the
front and there's only one seat
well i go i thought you said there was
two seats because no one's mine
because i go okay he goes yeah well
someone's gonna have to sit on my lap
and i'm like what
people were 14 15 years old i'm like
what do you talk to this yeah
once keeps mine so someone's got to sit
on my lap and i'm like i'm not doing
that my friend mike's like i'm not doing
that
and just about ready we're gonna go back
to the nosebleeds we see andre the giant
coming out
starting to match i'm like holy [__]
andre is right there
i'm like all right [__] it i'll sit on
your lap so i sat on the guy's lap
and he was holding me like we were like
you know when i was on a motorcycle
you know what i mean he's hugging me
like this
so i'm watching him oh my god this is
weird my friend mike's over here oh my
god i'm just focusing on the matching
this is strange but whatever and at one
point he nibbled on my ear
and like what the [__] was that he's
like i'm sorry i didn't mean it i'm like
that's [__] ridiculous what are you
doing
he's like i didn't mean it i'm sorry and
then i go mike you [__] get on his
lap now i'm done
so then mike went on his lap and he held
him like he was on a bike
and then i would see him after that i'd
see him and i'm like this guy's weird
and i'd see him at madison square garnet
my dad wasn't around i don't know where
he was he'd like hey give me a kiss on
the cheek and i'll give you this picture
and i go why because italian men do that
all the time they give a kiss
so i'm like now he said come on man i
haven't seen you in a while he goes look
i'll show you this picture you want us
you want this picture of superstar billy
graham like yeah he's like all right
[__] it i give him a kiss on
each side of his cheek
i still have the pictures i want the one
when he slept over jim that's the money
one
now that we get to there how do we get
to that three months later
um he convinces my parents to stay over
my house one night
because he knows all the kids in the
neighborhood because my dad would take
all the kids in the neighborhood we're
all 14 15 blonde hair blue eyes
nice little swimmers bodies you know
we're [__] young brad pitts
it's the burpee in new jersey this guy
was all over us we're [__] good bait
for him so my parents somehow decide
okay he could sleep over in the guest
room
which is weird but the guy was like 38
we were 14.
my dad met him a few times whatever so
he sleeps over and he go
he get my parents picked him up at night
like a friday night at the bus stop from
new york city lived in the city
they use can i go uh say hi to jim they
go no he's sleeping you'll see him in
the morning
he goes okay i wake up in the morning
the guy's got his hand down my pants
i have my little pjs on and he's got his
thumb through like a hole
by the crotch and i wake up like what
are you doing he goes i'm showing you a
magic trick
a magic trick because yeah what the [__]
are you talking about
you should take a magic kick hold on
hold on i can [__] you and i went to go
run the door to go tell my two older
brothers
who were suspicious of them to begin
with and he blocked the door he goes
listen
stop he goes i'll give you 30 pictures
out of any of my photo album here if you
don't say anything
i go 30.
whatever 30 you want the top ones you
could take
if you don't say a word i said okay fine
i'm like [__] it
you know i might as well get some
pictures out of this so i sat there i
picked out 30
as soon as i got the 30 i had in my hand
i ran i ran right out of the room opened
the door told my two older brothers joe
and bob you know him
and um they dragged him out of the house
into the car and they dropped them off
at the supermarket where the bus station
was
it was like six in the morning because
the newspapers are still out there you
know they used to stack the newspapers
out before the place was open
and they were hitting them over the head
with the newspapers and kicking them
and kicked his ass and put them back on
a bus to new york city
i saw the pictures i kept them because
my brother joe's like you got to give
the pictures back
you got to go tell dad what he did i go
i'm not telling that because he's going
to make me give the pictures back
i go i deserve these so i never told my
parents
because my mom would have said you have
to give the pictures back whatever who
knows what would have happened but i was
like [__] that i got
i got great pictures and he was never
seen again
no he would he yeah he was yeah he was
never seen again i heard
i i got someone sent me a picture of him
he's still alive he's he's living in
thailand he's
oh yeah yeah that's that's where you go
when you just want to [__] little kids
yeah he's still in thailand but this
just picture ivan koloff
with the belt he told me he goes if you
give me a kiss in the cheek this
this picture is going to be worth a lot
because he was only he was only the
champ for like nine days
he goes this is really rare this is
going to be worth a ton of money one day
so i gave him the kiss on the cheek i
looked it up like five years ago it's
worth nine
cents now ivan call off he was the
chancellor just they just made bruno san
martino the champ after that right
yeah in between the thing with madison
square garden there was so many italians
that loved bruno san martino because he
was italian that he had the belt for
like eight years because he could sell
out the garden every month
and all these italian men would go
including my dad so they had to keep
miss champ
because if they had another guy in there
they wouldn't go it would
be like when bob bakland was the champ a
couple years later
it would be a half a house every time so
vince mcmahon senior told bruno
you got to be the champ you got a big
italian following up after nine years
bruh goes i don't want the belt anymore
i'm too tired i'm beat up so i'm gonna
i'm i'm giving up the belt
but he but he told me and nine cents
this thing is worth he lied to me
he told me he was gonna be worth a lot
one that goes just for me like a mickey
mantle rookie car
we'll have to make it an nft we'll make
it an nft and [__] sell it and then
the price will go up on ivan [__]
whatever his name is
but you don't understand joey when i
told this story on howard stern i had at
least 20 different people contact me
guys and told me the same exact story
but he did it to them too
all over the country and one guy sent me
a picture of him i'll show you next time
he come over i don't want to show it on
here just a case
legally or whatever but i'll show you
what the guy looked like that is just
amazing and you know it's funny because
somebody else would have turned this
around this would have been like a
crutch for somebody
like we had puerto rican nelson he would
play football with us with a robe with
no underwear on
we knew he was a [__] pedophile so
we could either avoid him or use him
so we used him he liked to play football
and [__] like that he had a great arm
so we went out there knowing that he was
a pedophile and then he'd go if i do
this
are you guys gonna come over afterward
[__] yeah
we'll be over in [__] five minutes
we'll put our robes on too with no
underwear on
and then mr softy would come and he
would get all excited
buy us ice cream and then we would tell
him to suck our dick cut the [__] out of
here when i go into your backyard
you pervert [__] and then he
would do it again two weeks later
we would just it was a constant thing
like he would think that we forgot that
he was a [__] pedophile
yeah and there were a couple reports in
the neighborhood i really never
confirmed them but it wasn't it's so
weird like
if this was california you know your
parents would have called the cops your
brothers everybody
here in jersey we just handle a
different way we hit him with newspapers
and we [__] we torment their lives
you know with nelson
i can't remember what you know what
happened to him but i'm sure
that we tortured him until he [__]
left because that was our style eggs you
know light your [__]
you know your welcome carpet you know
how many of those i lit on fire at his
house
we would just throw [__] uh uh
lighting fluid and light his [__]
welcome sign on fire once we knew he was
a pedophile
he couldn't [__] with us you know yeah
yeah i mean like you know uh
we just you know he the guy pretty much
disappeared from there but yeah i mean
you just
who knew back then you know like our
parents will let us hang out with the
priests too
go go camping with them go away from a
weekend you need another
you know adult uh male in your life you
know
he'll teach you the right way and [__]
like that that should happen all the
time
i mean i was an altar boy all that stuff
i never went away with the priest but
the local the priests in our town where
i grew up that the
catholic school i went to he they
shipped them out they found that he did
some dirty [__]
another priest in there if they found it
he did some dirty [__] too
so but our parents trusted us he trusted
those people
including the wrestling picture guy
thinking ah
you know he's a little weird but
whatever
you didn't think that [__] back then
that's why the parents let the kids hang
out with the priests and stuff
how are we as parents we don't trust
nobody no there's no way like you and i
they they know like listen
you can tell whatever story you want and
i'll warn you too like listen i know you
i know what
you're doing i know that you're a
[__] pedophile and if you [__]
touch her
i'm gonna hit you in the head with a
brick like you just as a parent now you
look at it and you're like
you see you know i see it i i see the
walk
i see the talk it's tough to be a
pedophile now it's not like the [__]
well now they're on the computer you
know so you got to watch
what your kids bust into you know i
thought about it
my dream in life is to definitely bust
into a zoom meeting with my ball sack
i just don't know how to hack into a
like a city town
council board meeting when people are
yelling about zoning a chinese church
and i just take a picture of my balls
and say [__] you [__]
don't put no church i'm dying to do that
i just don't know how to be a hacker you
know i don't
i don't know i don't [__] know so
yeah anyway i don't even know how i got
on that
rumor about it like my one brother he
always said he's got the daughter you
know which one i'm talking about and
he's already he says to his daughter hey
if she's like 12 hey if um
if some guy comes up blows up in a band
and you don't know what do you do
you go she goes get in the van with them
and his mother goes
i'm stop saying that my sister don't say
that get in the van when i'm
like
you got you know i think that
like for me i got to be very very like i
was watching the summer of sam
on your recommendation you know and i
think episode 3 they talk about the guy
that was very catholic
that he lived close to the church so
they always called him when he was
when this an altar boy didn't show up i
listen i could lift my right hand to god
i wasn't an altar boy because i didn't
like all the work and there was no cash
in it you know
if not i would have became an altar boy
yo if you did a funeral they would give
you cash
like if you were an altar boy at a
funeral so we'd always fight to do
what we could do to funerals yeah but
how much cash like a five or a 10.
yeah go [__] yourself i could work bingo
and steal 40
and make [__] 40 on a sunday night
from 6 to 9.
so [__] that [__] i'm gonna [__] go
in there with that pedophile smoke
and help him distribute that [__] in
church [__] you
i knew early on that i love my priest
listen
i know i still remember my priest that
did the the
you know holy communion he was a [__]
g
the priest that did my wedding my first
wedding was a g
he was into coke he knew all about drugs
and [__] we talked about he lived in san
francisco
and the guy that made my confirmation
was his father tom the same guy that did
that
and there was no pedophilia with these
guys i checked them out you know
i tested them i would take a ball out in
front of them and see if they would
react
you know you got to test them and [__]
like that but uh
no i never had a negative experience at
the catholic church i feel bad for
people
who did i did have a negative experience
with the boy scouts of america
yeah that i knew i knew they were creepy
i felt that at my first wee blue meeting
and i didn't like being a wee blow i
didn't like that word right there off
the bat that made me sound like a half a
fruitcake
so we're not blowing nobody i don't want
to be a [__] weeblow i think i lasted
three meetings and that was the end of
that
yeah i never did that my parents
actually signed me up to be at all the
ball i didn't want to be because i was
getting in so much trouble i thought it
would straighten me out
i i i enjoyed the church i went to
church this week
i went on sunday finally with the family
and it was uh a little on the weird side
it was and i had a buddy call me the
night before
who's a dear friend of mine i've known
him since the sixth grade
and he's in recovery so he went from a a
to n a because they don't mention god
and he gave me a ferocious ear beating
on the way to [__] play a bowl the
other day about how you have to
invite god into your life he's the
perfect gentleman
so while i'm in church sunday with my
family this is all i'm thinking about
you know is
now i invited god into my family and
that's what i need now but
it was fun i liked the church it was
quick 15 minutes no drama no handshakes
everybody wore a mask this is a very
nice area
very nice people the italians have taken
over we got great places to eat
right the food's phenomenal let's just
hope god likes edibles
if he's in your life yes but guess what
i just been eating edibles to go to
sleep
jesus christ i've been switching like
every night you know how i switch i take
magnesium something i do everything
last night i went off i knew i could
sleep a little late
so i made a michael jackson tea holy
[__]
it took me forever to wake up this
morning i was up at seven
what's the michael jackson teeth that's
the two bags of tea from kikimo
a couple capsules from [__] uh abx
three or four that's got to be 400
milligrams
and then i just shoot 897 milligrams of
thc into a cup i stir it a little bit
and bottoms up i i drink it during the
first half hour of miami vice
once i stopped getting bored i pull out
the guitar and i start practicing
[__] crazy train that's it
until i get too high to remember the
chords
and then i go nappy new new that's great
man
that you know like i would you know when
you were moving here i was like man i
gotta
you know all my family and friends
they're abrasive and they're [__]
weird and they
they bust balls and i have these two
guys that come over my house every
sunday to watch football
and i was like [__] i don't know if i'm
gonna tell talk to my brother dan i'm
like i don't know if i can buy joey over
they're gonna go
attack them they're gonna find one fault
on him and just go after him
and he's like yeah i go i think he could
take it i mean he grew up in jersey
i go i i warned you like 10 times before
you came over
don't worry man i'm fine i'm fine i'm
still i'm still nervous because i'm not
going to tell those guys not
to you know hey com calm it down they do
what they do
they do what they do yeah so you i never
forget you came over the first week of
football
those guys were you know saying all this
crazy [__]
going after you you're going after them
back and forth and i remember walking
you out
on my driveway and you turn around it
goes jimmy i haven't seen guys like that
in 35 years i thought they were all dead
i didn't think they still existed
because you grew up with guys like that
oh my god i love guys like that yeah
that's my world to take guys like that
out whatever they want they want coke
give them coke
give them extra coke cause they're gonna
start trouble and then three weeks later
one of them's chasing you in my basement
naked
naked he was chasing me but the best was
when he got naked and waited for you to
come out of the bathroom
and i was actually sitting there so i
took a picture of him naked
and i got high that afternoon and i
forgot that i had the picture and that
night
i'm going through my pictures and i see
a picture of a naked man i'm like what
the [__] is wrong with me
and i'm like oh that's right he was
waiting outside jimmy's door
in a superman stance with his pants down
to his knees
but how childish you know what i mean
like i'm in the bathroom and he's just
waiting for me
so i open the door and he's standing
there naked i'm like ah it's it's
something you do when you're 12 years
old but it's still funny
but your reaction was priceless because
you've seen this dick a thousand times
you just walked right past it yeah like
not yet
like some guy was handing you a flyer
you're like no i'll take it next time
yes make it again okay yeah those guys
that get naked you can't give him light
because then they'll really [__] he
chased me
he chased me naked and i'm like what the
[__] do i do
you know like when a man chases you
naked you don't know how many times i
chased rogan with my balls out
and he would threaten me joey i'm gonna
hit you and he would run he would run no
guy wants to be chased
that's a man's biggest fear there's a
guy chasing you with his dick out
guys wake up once in their lifetime
going oh my god a guy was chasing me
with his dick out
because there's no defense technique for
that you could join 20 martial arts
schools
and there's no defense if a guy comes at
you with an eight-inch dick
nothing but muscles and veins and blood
you know
that was great because you you said the
next day you talked to rogan on the
phone you go
joe a 55 year old man chased around
jimmy florentine's basement yesterday
he goes i'm around my people this is
where i need to be
i never forget i'm around my people this
is where i need to i do
you know my biggest excuse my biggest
thing about l.a was that i loved it i
prospered there i
i became a comic there i met my wife
there there was so many great things
but towards the last four years the
connection was getting
bigger and bigger i was becoming
something
in that neighborhood that i didn't want
to become like i just wanted to be a
regular [__] guy
i don't want to take pictures at the
park or do any of that [__] at the park
when i'm with my kids
so this coming here
just leveled me the [__] out it just
reminded me that we're just [__]
jersey guys this is great just going
down the shore and
and you know getting chased by a naked
guy on a sunday and it was
you know i went every sunday and
it was very it brought me back to who i
was
it brought me back a lot little by
little i'm becoming
i told my wife two days ago i'm not joey
anymore
i'm coco again i can feel coco coming
back i could feel the attitude
the views you know and in time
you know what i think i'm gonna talk to
a therapist maybe now that you said you
had one maybe i'll talk to him and
see what the [__] is going on with me
why i haven't smoked dope or want to do
comedy or nothing like that
stopped eating cheeseburgers what the
[__] stops eating pizza when they moved
to jersey me
i'm the only jerk off you know so uh but
i i really want to thank you man this
has been a [__]
great experience from the music we trade
albums we go album shopping
you know the ozzie's boneyard i just
listened to you this morning
this has just been uh i just wanted to
be [__]
normal jim no it look when you and when
you got kids man it's about them
growing up and you know giving them a
good life you know and so it's not about
you anymore
it's cliche but it's true it's like you
gotta i see all the call
your daughter's got friggin 15 friends
already she's been here for like three
months
you know what i mean and my kids got a
bunch of friends and that's what it's
about them hanging out you can have a
sleepover
they're over there the parents are
dropping them off like that's what it is
being a kid
and that's why i had to get out of north
jersey because i lived in a high-rise
i'm like he's gonna have no friends
you know what i mean he's gonna have no
backyard to play on not to play football
so i need to do it for him
you know if i gotta make a sacrifice and
you gotta make a sec it's
and then we still can go out and do our
thing you know what i mean you just
juggle both schedules
as you get older you realize it's not
about doing stand-up you know three sets
a night seven nights a week just living
in that
that's all you want to know you don't
want to know anything else going your
kids like sporting events i like
i look forward to that just as much as i
look forward to getting up on stage
still
like my kids got a game i can't wait i'm
more excited than he is
jimmy i could look you in the eye and
anybody else and tell you that if you
if i thought i wasn't going to enjoy a
girls softball game as much as i am
lately
i i i tell you you were [__] crazy if
somebody came up to me and said in two
years
you're going to be going to girls
softball games and you're going to have
a good time i would have said
you're just a [__] idiot you don't
know me i can't tell you last friday
night the parents brought white claws
they had white claws hot dogs they were
out there
living it up drinking yeah that's great
and i'm the only [__] there sober as
a judge now all of a sudden now i decide
to get sober
now is when i needed an edible out there
the sun was shining
they had [__] peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches for the kids
they brought twizzlers for the kids for
after the game whether they win or lose
it's something that i never had in my
life i never had normality in my life
like this my mother was a functioning
alcoholic
i left the house whenever the [__] i
wanted to and i came in when i wanted
this life you know going to your son's
games with you
you know going to your family functions
all the other family fun
i just got invited to a family function
saturday afternoon you know
it's it's what i wanted i was sick and
tired of
being alone in california it was a great
experience and i miss a lot of my
friends
but it was time to grow
to move here for my daughter this move
was not for me for me to advance my
career
i didn't move here to be on law and
order organized crime
it popped up after i didn't move here
well
i did move here because it was legal
marijuana i'm not gonna lie to nobody
that was that made it enticing also i
moved here so my daughter
could go to white castle my daughter
could drink a yoo-hoo
my daughter could have a [__] slice
of pizza my daughter could go to the
quarry
how great is that brony brook parked by
a house
when they went [__] snow skiing
that's free yeah
yeah that's free you know you only got
to be careful in the winter time because
they could do here
deer hunting up there i found out you
might get shot with a bow and arrow
so you don't want to go up there in the
[__] uh no you know what's great is
like
the the people around here in this area
or whatever just in the
general the moms want to be moms
unlike l.a unlike wherever new york
whatever like that they
just they're just they're happy just
being moms and it's all about their kids
and i like seeing that because you get
jaded
when you're on the road and you see
these crazy women they're drunk and
they're
yelling [__] after a show and they got
kids or whatever like that but you just
i really see like wow these people are
normal people i didn't see that for a
long time i mean i grew up normal
my parents were married 33 years great
couple and a lot we had seven kids but
you just see around here these mom that
you're just totally invested in their
kids and i love seeing that
i love it too i love it uh to the point
where i mean
we've even like i said we've turned this
block around
just by me going outside and knocking on
people's door you know when the
when the pandemic came around in l.a i
knocked on my neighbor's door and i went
i bought a batch of
uh masks i thought i was doing the right
thing these people did everything but
throw the masks in my face
you know at the beginning of pandemic
nobody knew anything nobody really had a
choice to make
i thought i was doing the right thing
here you knocking a neighbor's door
they're gracious they talk to you some
of them knock on my door
you don't know how many nights i'm
sitting down here the neighbors just
knock on my door hated
did an elk go in your backyard you know
little things that you know
they're not calling me to ask me if i
knew about the new
[__] ray romano movie you know what
i'm saying like
that [__] just gets old what's going on
in your world i know you're touring a
lot
yeah i i i i feel like i could be your
agent
because every club i go to everyone's
like hey i want joey here
shall we ready to do stand up again yeah
i want to book him
can you give me his number i really
could be your agent i every club i go to
when show it coming back out come on
what's going on just told me to do
whatever i'm like when he's ready he'll
come back out
he will but i go now right now no i'm
back you know things are opening up i'm
doing some shows and i'm filming a
comedy special like in july
where's the special at it's uh saturday
july 24th at the fairfield theater in
fairfield connecticut
and you're just shooting an independent
rough [__] it no commitments to nobody
worst case scenario youtube gets it
exactly
yep no pressure doing two shows in one
night a little theater there
they got six six camera shoot all that
stuff they do a whole stream and thing
out of there too so
yeah i'm gonna shoot it that night i've
been working on the material for a while
and uh it's ready
yeah now you know so if people want to
go to uh on my website jimflorenty.com
or the ticket link will be there but
it's
i love it because you send all your fans
to my shows uncle joey sent me uncle
joey sent me
whenever i meet him afterwards i'm like
thank you i appreciate it well you know
i try to listen i sell them
i send them to your show i send them to
rich's show
i send them to rob kelly's show
especially during the pandemic
because i wanted people to know that
listen it's not about podcasting it's
not about
who's in what movie these are guys that
are bringing you
entertainment while the country while
the world is suffering
the least you could do you're getting
that [__] unemployment check with the
extra three bills
you don't like jimmy florentine because
he thought he likes queens reich
but he doesn't like uriah he that's fine
okay
he doesn't like mata hoople so you
disagree with jimmy but do me a favor
just pay the 15 bucks ticket and
somebody will take it support live
comedy support the arts
you know i'm not a musician but ever
since i started playing the guitar i've
been supporting little musician things
asbury park there was one up north in
newark for
struggling musicians what's a hundred
dollars kind of duty it's
not gonna make me a [__] break me and
some poor guy that's been playing the
guitar
for 20 years that nobody looked at and i
got that from you
you always told me that that you always
buy
uh your friend's musics just to support
the band i
apple yeah i buy i body album even
though i got itunes so i can
i pay 10 bucks a month for apple music i
buy the album for 9.99
on itunes just to support when i go to a
concert they hook me up with tickets
or whatever i always buy a couple
concert t-shirts dude you support i know
that's going in their pockets so
and this is why i send people to your
show because
i know you're doing the right thing and
life is a [__] circle
it's a circle we help musicians we're
all a bunch of failed musicians we
didn't have the balls
to [__] stick it out in a band with
drums with five other guys
we decided we wanted to do it ourselves
but you and i
we how much do we admire musicians i
mean you know
your brother's offering me five grand to
blow halford
if nobody [__] knows
the best of my brother gave joey a
scenario he's like would you blow ralph
halfer for like a million dollars it was
or something
saved the world from aids well no no he
you he's he said that you would
there'd be no more coronavirus if you
blow like
yeah rob halpert or whatever like that
and you're like no man i know
and i go and i'll never forget you're
walking out of my base my brother goes
joey no one's gonna know if you do it
and you just turn around you go
i'll know that's it no oh no i gotta
look at that mirror see this ugly face
and no i sucked rob alpha's dick and
that's a [__] nightmare
that i'll never finish the [__] book
he led me
thank you very much for taking the time
today buddy i know that you're busy
i know your son's getting home any
minute now and uh any other dates you
want to push while you're here
i want these people to support jack well
fairfield connecticut
saturday july 24th i'll be doing two
shows that night so come on out
and uh yeah that'd be great and
hopefully jim will be having an nft
soon also i'm trying to hook him up for
like uh heavy metal
nfps i gotta say one thing joey
you know he's he's put stand up on hold
but i saw the sets he was doing on uncle
vinnie's on wednesday nights
he's 75 to 80 ready to get out there and
kill
you weren't even you were like i'm not
really happy with the material you were
killing and the material is great so
when you're ready
you know what i mean to get back out
there you already got a big hunk of new
stuff that's great that was old [__]
not all it was yes it was i was talking
about my gay neighbor bob
my gay bob i don't have a gay bob
neighbor so i can't use it on stage no
more
so it was all these old jokes that never
got put on a special
that now i can't put out because i don't
even think that way no more
i wish i had a gay bob next to me i wish
i had gay bob living next to me
you know telling me how he's busting
[__] every week in
asbury park and [__] but i don't so
i can't use that material no more my
thinking is different my daughter's
older
but i have been you know when i play the
guitar at night
i kind of feel [__] and i'll make little
notes i took my computer pad that had
a bunch of material on it and i erased
it and i just broke it down
who the [__] am i today so i've been
making little notes
so when it's time i think i'll go out
there i still owe uncle vinnie
three dates which i'm gonna fulfill
cause he's the best in the business
and then uh i'll probably be out there
for soprano time
do a [__] uh jersey strong show with
my man florentine
and rich voss will take over new jersey
for the month of october
yo joey i'm your you're like a band that
you're like come on would they just do
some shows that are going to announce a
tour damn that another summer without
doing it
that build up right now i can feel it
from the fans that come to my show
when does joey get back out there what
is he getting back out there so
well i i'm also looking at instagram
and i'm seeing dead companies coming out
sebastian's coming out tom segura is
coming out
and as a as a human being as an
economist
uh an econ major where's all this money
going to come from
what's all the concerts that are going
on all the concerts that are going to
come where are these people
you're going to kill me from september
to december the eagles
you know uh i think rage the other thing
that rage
the other partners are out and rage
black black rose are out
black crows are out you know i know def
leppard pushed their tour back till
2022.
green day's doing a stadium tour so
where is all this money coming from
so before i abuse the country and try to
[__]
because we're all chasing the same
[__] nickel
let me get my head right let me do my
warm-up shows at vinnie's
maybe do a couple guest sets at your
shows rich voss is doing
east brunswick with you let me just get
my feet back on to me the other thing is
my knee's not 100 right
i crack some joke about eating [__]
some guy's a christian he shoots a gun i
can't run i get shot
because my knees are all [__] up so my
knees got to be tip top magoo jimmy
for me to go back out there but i know
they're looking forward to you getting
back out there and you know it too but
they i i'm out there so i see it
no we're gonna do it and i'll probably
do guest sets at your shows uh
as a secret and i'll see you later every
show i do real quick every show i do
people afterwards i thought joey was
going to come out whether i'm in las
vegas
florida they think like you flew with me
today i thought joey was going to come
out
i figured you is going to come out after
you right before you oh my god
will i see you tonight you'll be around
yeah i'll be around yeah we're done at 7
30 so i don't know if you have a game
we're done at 7 30 from freehold
we probably won't be back till 8 but uh
it was a pleasure talking to you
and i want to thank you for having the
best family on the east coast
they opened up their hearts to me i'm
writing a book with erica
i'm doing mugs with paula you know
you're you know
me and bob are [__] crypto buddies
now
i love you with all my heart luke is my
little roberto clemente
you know the florentine crime family
shirts will be out soon
and we're going to have them numbered so
get ready for the florentine crime
family shirts [__]
all proceeds go to the ac dc party we're
having on june 4th
i love you jim thank you for your time
buddy next time we'll do it over there
in the brick wall
yeah absolutely yeah all right you back
[__] i hope you enjoyed jimmy
we're for [__] when he told me the
story about the wrestler
biting his ear nibbling on his ear when
he first told me that story
i [__] told my wife we were down here
in the basement watching tv hat
because he would come over when i had
the knee surgery and just talk with me
in the afternoons
for an hour that's how good he is and
like i said during the podcast
today with him guys we're to a point now
where you know who my friends are
from bert tom joe
duncan red band tony hinchcliffe
d'alia listen they all have faults
some of them don't have faults some of
them have been in trouble
guess what they come to your town if you
love me
these guys have bent over backwards for
me
when somebody remember i'm the enemy of
your enemy
but i'm also the best friend of your
best friend
when these guys come to your town
whether you like that comedy whether
you're busy
support them buy a ticket who gives a
[__]
buy a cd you know keep the karma well
like i said told him during the thing
i'm not a musician i played the guitar
for three months i know two songs
but you got to hear my smoke on the
water it sounds like
the [__] water disappeared but i
still want to help out musicians with
the money that you sent me on patreon
we've helped out two music festivals i
don't know anybody in those festivals
but those are the ones that need more of
our help
rage against a machine doesn't need my
hundred dollars
[__] alice in chains doesn't need my
kiss definitely doesn't need my hundred
dollars that poor band and long branch
that they've been struggling all year
they're four kids they work at a print
shop
you know what man they get a hundred
dollar check in the mail
that boosts your [__] morale that's a
pair of symbols that's four [__]
guitar picks
that's something so right now pandemic
whatever there's a season to look after
your friends
and to look after the people that have
made you you that's the most important
thing
and jimmy florentine and his family have
made me me
this is why i look the way i am this is
why i have the happiness i
am this is why i'm in a good [__]
mood even though i haven't smoked reefer
in [__] two weeks [__]
it's sober in may uncle joey's doing
sober and [__] may
everybody was doing sober in october i
got to be the jerk off that has to be
sober in may but it feels good
i'm happy i'm doing it my lungs needed
to breathe i needed a breather
everybody needed to breathe you don't
need to see me smoke pot no more that's
it it's all over
but i will be making a comeback i will
keep you [__] posted
because i will tape it i want to drool
in front of you i want to do that whole
thing i want to do like a lease i at
and out of space with my eyes roll back
to my head
and you guys like finally we [__] got
him
anyway i love you [__] have a
great weekend
thank you for watching thank you for
listening god bless you [__] stay
black
and i'll see you next [__] monday tip
top
[__] magoo stay black thank you
and now
for a word for my sponsor all right
i want to thank jim florentine i want to
thank you guys for supporting
and i want to thank you for all the love
and uh hope you give us you know i'm
saying things are rough out there for a
pimp
and we're still here doing our
[__] thing but the joint today
is brought to you by
magnesium breakthrough listen to me you
can't sleep you [__] toss and turn
it's time to squash that [__] with
magnesium if you can't sleep if you
tried everything
tryptophal melatonin hitting yourself in
the head with a hammer
it's probably because your magnesium is
low i didn't know anything about
magnesium
i'm not going to sit here and tell you i
was a magnesium [__] specialist
my agent sent me this like in december
and i started taking it because
magnesium and vitamin d were good
against [__] uh covid but little did
i know
that it helps activate the transmitters
in your brain that calm the mind and the
body
what's better than that you guys know i
take my sleeping serious
for years i [__] off i didn't take
naps as a kid
and that's why i got all fat and [__]
because no [__] sleep
now that i've been sleeping i'm better
off i'm losing weight the weights coming
off me i'm feeling better
it's the only organic magnesium
supplement that includes
seven seven unique forms of magnesium
that's the full spectrum it's helped
tons of people
i could read that testimonials all day
but here's mine
listen my recovery is better i've been
working out four days a week
and that's because of magnesium
especially
from magnesium breakthrough they also
have the enzymes they also have the apex
the bio apex that bio optimizes
you got to take a look at this you
understand me the mass enzymes have 17's
enzymes
including protease per capsules and it's
great to process
protein the other thing that's helped me
a lot is the probiotics
the ps3 the navy seals the probiotics
that's why i've lost the late the weight
because i'm digesting
they got some great stuff that magnesium
breakthrough
so go over there right now and take a
look at their website
go to magne magbreakthrough.com
joey like i told you earlier it takes a
lot to take this bull down
at night and magnesium breakthrough
works
if you're having trouble falling asleep
or staying asleep make sure you're
getting enough magnesium
and please do not run to the grocery
store for this
most magnesium supplements are cheap and
since they're not full spectrum
they won't actually fix your magnesium
deficiency
there are actually seven forms of
magnesium and you must get all of them
if you want the experiencing and calming
sleep enhancing effects
that's why i recommend magnesium
breakthrough
the mass enzymes and the apex just pop
two capsules before you go to bed
and you'll be out like a [__] light
scene [__] nanny nunu
thinking about uncle joey chasing you
last night i had a dream that fidel
castro was chasing me on a boat
that's when you know you have [__]
problems and that's when you know you
got deep sleep
do me a favor go to magbreakthrough.com
right now
slash showy for my listeners right now
use promo code joey10
write it down joey j o e y 10
and write down magbreakthrough.com
joey mag m-a-g breakthrough
b-r-e-a-k t-h-r-o-u-g-h
dot com slash joey use promo code joey10
and i'm gonna give you 10 off on the
best [__] magnesium out in the
in the [__] world that's how i look
at it why
because it [__] helps me sleep why do
i love the mass
enzymes because it helps my digestion
and the p3om the navy seals of
probiotics
but it starts with you you got to go to
magbreakthrough.com right now
slash showy and when you see the sandman
tell them uncle joey told you to tell
them to suck your dick
i love you [__] have a great
weekend
may 19th i will see you monday morning
tip top magoo ready to stab a [__]
circus clown
i love you [__] stay black have a
great weekend
[Music]
so
you